Let's go next to our caller from the six three
one area code.
Who's calling today from six, three one
I think that's me.
A. Am I on?
Yes.
Who's this?
Hi, my name is art.
Wow.
I actually didn't think I'd actually have
the chance to on, I've been trying for a while.
Here you are.
I'm a big fan of the show.
Yeah.
All right, so we're at this, right.
My question is it phase a sort of a pattern
I'm sort of seeing from like, not all, but
a good number of people from the Republican
party is that a lot of them are asking the
question of, of doing the right thing, whether
do I do what's good for me?
And, and, and through that I think they sort
of developed or at least forgotten the difference
between being tough and being callous towards
certain people and certain issues.
You see what I'm getting at here?
Only sort of explain it to me in another way.
Okay.
Well a lot of the whole people, the Trump
administration says, we gotta be tough on
crime.
You gotta be tough on immigrants.
We gotta be tough on drugs, tough on all this
stuff.
But they don't know that.
They can't separate that toughness from being
just completely indifferent from the suffering
of others.
Like the reason I am the way I am now.
It's because I was taught to always empathize
with people.
Not sure.
Maybe to a certain point, but, but do you
think like somehow they've allowed the people
now with him, this is completely lost all
sense of empathy.
Yeah.
This is not a new thing.
This is, this is not a new thing.
Listen, I'm going to let you go and answer
it offline because your connection is not
the best right now.
You're cutting in and out.
But the, I've been talking about this for
a long time.
When a Republican has a personal connection
to something, they will often come around
like when they have a gay relative, for example.
And when that happens, we're happy.
But at the same time it's disappointing and
disheartening that only when it personally
affects them do they actually reconsider how
other people are being affected by the policies
that they pushed.
So yeah, you've identified something that
is an absolute reality and I don't believe
that it is unfortunately new, uh, to Donald
Trump.
Hope to hear from you again, hopefully with
a better connection next time.
Let's go to our caller from the nine one two
area code.
Who's calling today from nine one two.
Hello David.
I'm Sebastian from Savannah.
I read this article on box from Zack Bal champ
about his change of mind on impeachment.
He stated that his inquiry about the inquiry
is about what is happening currently and in
the future 2020 election.
This impeachment is about what's he's doing
right now.
The previous calls in for impeachment were
for the Muller probe were about previous actions
and did not merit impeachment.
I know your take on this is different, but
it is quite compelling for me for the justification
of impeachment.
Now.
Thank you for taking my call.
David.
Sorry.
So whose opinion is this?
Are you reading someone else's opinion?
I didn't hear who it was.
Yeah.
Uh, this is from, uh, this is, uh, an opinion
from Zack bowel champ from box.
Okay.
All right.
And he says that this is different than previous
calls for impeachment because it's about Trump's
current actions rather than previous actions.
Exactly.
He says that because this is happening right
now and within like it's within, it's right
in front of us and we have the evidence right
in front of it that we do have impeachment.
And to me it is a pretty justification for
impeachment.
There's no question you all need, you need
the inquiry to explore whether an impeachment
trial is the right next step and then the
Senate needs to vote.
So I think you are 100% right or, or mr Zack
Beauchamp is right in pointing out that this
relates to something that is now like this
really, you know, it's been the last three
months that this Ukraine stuff has been going
on.
That doesn't give us the answer as to whether
it is something the president should be removed
from office for.
That's why we're starting this process.
But I agree that that's a key difference from
the Mueller stuff, which was trying to figure
out what took place back in 2015 and 2016.
Yeah.
And I understood your, uh, take on both, um,
your original, um, opinion on this new impeachment,
and I knew that, uh, this would be a little
bit different,
but this is the only impeachment inquiry,
right?
I mean, this is w there was
well did calls for impeachment, the world
calls for impeachment.
You know, I remember, you know how Democrats
were trying to say, you know, they wanted
impeachment because of the Mueller probe and
you were saying it.
It's not, that's not happening.
Yeah, it's, and there is no way it's going
to happen.
But with this, this is completely diff.
All right, Sebastian, point well made.
I appreciate you making it and I hope to hear
from you again in the future.